where I try to say this to everyone and
they hate hearing it let me ask you a
question real quick and we don't have to
you you bought your house so your house
is in a you could say where you live if
you want but we'll say it's a nice
neighborhood that still has some issues
in San Francisco it's like I would say
one of the less nice neighborhoods
overall but it's still desirable because
it's like in a hipster area
do you regret buying your home yes do
you as your what you can want to say
what your rights is is that your new
house or not yeah sure so the new house
front is seven grand a monk and was that
less than your mortgage
yeah it's less overall because with a
house you have you know property tax you
have your mortgage and then you have
like you know sort of the house
maintenance issues that come up over
time that you know we're just
miscellaneous things do you think you'll
make it a bit money a little bit less
but similar you think you're gonna make
any money off of this deal not really
and that's good you know because selling
house has a lot of fees so like you know
when you buy a house if you want to sell
it the next day you basically need to
sell it for 5% more just with the broker
fees and then there's like the transfer
tax and then there's you know all the
staging costs you know it's gonna cost
us 15 grand to stage the place and fix
up the paint and the you know little
scuffs and scratches that we've had
along the way and then our you know we
didn't take care of a long as good as we
should have so we gotta get a landscaper
so there's all these costs to selling so
it's gonna come out that you broke even
any wood for free or as they come out
that you just lived for a crate or
whatever the yeah I lived for I lived it
basically about what I could have lived
renting it or maybe a little bit ahead
we'll see how it Nets out like it's
unknown right like with the cove it and
stuff like we don't even know you know
for somebody to come do an open house
tours like a lot of friction now it's
like wear your mask signed this waiver
blah blah blah so I don't know where
it's gonna sell for but the reason I
regret it is not because of any of that
you know right before I bought the house
like I had been house hunting and like a
week before I was hanging out with soui
Antilles you know 100 times wealthier
than I am and I asked him I said do you
own your place and I was hanging out at
his house he says no
why don't you own like you know just the
most baller house here because you could
and he was like oh yeah no I like the
you know I like the flexibility on taint
blah blah and I was like mmm it seems
like he just kind of didn't give me the
full answer there so I asked him it
again at the very end up walking st.
want to make you feel bad yeah I was
walking to my uber and I was like so if
you were me would you buy and he goes no
I hope wait why and he goes he goes
really simple he's like I just think I
can get a better cap rate and better
return on my money essentially doing
other things than than buying a home so
like you know you put your down payment
down 20% your home in our case 25% and
that money sits in your home and it's
appreciating at the rate of your home
appreciation which is like you know very
specific well I think yeah historically
across all homes I think it's 3% yeah
exactly the San Francisco did a lot
better during a certain era where was
like 10-15 percent a year but his point
was basically like yeah like I know that
my if I take all my options for how to
deploy a dollar you know stock market I
can expect about a 7% return and you
know I can do private you know startup
investing I can do private equity I can
put my money hedge fine I can do multi
kind of real estate there's like all
these things I can do putting it into a
down payment of a house is not the best
way and on top of that it doesn't spit
off any cash flow so like if I do if I
just buy a home and I rent it out to
someone I get the appreciation of a home
plus I get the cash flow every month
we're trying to say this to everyone and
they hate hearing it and I understand
why they keep hearing it but I think
buying how in our in our in Austin all
of our staff buys homes
and I'm like look don't tell me you're
buying this house because it's a good
investment tell me you're buying this
house because you want to like when I
bought my stake last night I didn't
think that this $30.00 is a good
investment I did it because I thought
why not a financial investment but a
good investment
like it made me happy I wanted it I work
hard so I can have things I want so if
you're so like if you buy your house
don't tell me you're doing it because
it's you're just throwing away money on
rent right tell me you're doing it
because it's gonna make you happier
because you want to because that is a
good reason but to say that it's an
investment that's you could say
that it's a great way to preserve wealth
but it absolutely in most cases is not a
great way to make it what else right
yeah exactly yeah and and I don't blame
anybody who thinks that I thought that
five seven years ago I
also said right isn't renting like
flushing money down the toilet and if
you buy your home you have equity and
blah blah blah and I learned pretty
quickly first person I talked to they
were like no that's not exactly how it
works so yeah if you haven't gone down
that rabbit hole go down the red hole
because they sort of American dream of
like own your own home with your you
know your white picket fence in your
backyard that is pretty silly and yeah
it also made a lot more sense with the
ratio of income to housing prices was
closer than it is now now it's
significantly different out of that and
you face like you know risk right like
when I'm in my home and now boom remote
work is on the rise being in a city is
not not the thing anymore it's like oh
you know people take it for granted
that these things just sort of go up and
you know you're one shift away you know
as soon as elem us can make the
Hyperloop work where I can commute long
distances in like 20 minutes or less
then people are gonna want to go live
further away have way more you know
space resources and whatnot and not want
to be impacted you know like I sardine
into a city a lot of people will choose
that and so your one technological shift
or one policy shift or in this case one
policy plus biological you know terror
away from not wanting people not wanting
to be in a certain type of real estate
class like the way the real estate is
now struggling because of because of
what's going on you get a whole lot of
unemployment and now people can't pay
the rents and you know every month rents
are dropping it was like 99 percent of
people pay their rent last month on the
multifamily stuff that I I read ninety
percent of people are paying their rent
and if that dips below you know a
certain number maybe it's 82 percent or
whatever it is now all of a sudden
you're underwater in a multi-family real
estate the way that I like to live
because so I've been an entrepreneur
since I was 16 making money on my own
not necessarily all the time a lot of a
lot of money but like having to like go
out and hunt and kill each week and I
like am allergic to like really big
purchases and I'm allergic to getting
locked into stuff and I actually think
that me being allergic to that has
actually hurt me I think that had I
increased my overhead on some things my
overheads really cheap I had I increased
my overhead I actually would have worked
harder to like have to like fulfill that
overhead but
now I mean if I don't work for many for
very long I don't even know how long
maybe forever I'm fine and I just prefer
to be on that defense cockroach than
putting you know and say forces so you
got to put down three or four hundred
thousand dollars on home I'm like a
I don't wanna that's scary I don't want
to do that you know what I mean yeah and
so I've never had the courage to do it
[Music]
[Applause]